okay guys we're back we're back
hey what's carabao
Shannon here he checked everything out
here or you or you or you aren't you
gonna count it on my middle set that
[ __ ]
can you take a carry one right you make
that gone well a fellow who's that you
do he's done who y'all
it has been a little while I will say
that okay yeah step out no scam Oh kevie
boot down alright yeah
what [ __ ] do I not have any oh my god I
cannot believe I did that
if I use up everything freaking person
Jesus Christ okay all right I guess
that's that
Oh Fredo very locked ready now that
really other stress
yeah I can't see where we're going I
think we're just considering the road
right okay all right let's say yeah I
know we do that carry the harsh reality
that his body also needed nurse
especially in the dead of winter for
this custom it
get out of here
by the music chance
is [ __ ] up
so like the [ __ ] light and then like
I like to stick our layers of snow so he
could just like wait attempts
and I like that one
like the whole Russian song
it was loitering somewhere you know
carl shivered as he saw the envelope the
patriot flag used during the 1837
rebellion and which had resurfaced in
1970s quebec flown proudly by the FLQ
terrorism perfect
this flag business kidnapping threats in
the papers that truck had obviously seen
its share of gravel roads Carl wasn't a
mechanic but he could easily tell that
only the most heartfelt prayer would
bring this baby back from its lumber
with that cold however it was more
likely that it would wait until next
spring to wake up I guess with a
homemade shooting range such as this it
wasn't hard to imagine a stray bullet
ending its course inside the flesh of an
unsuspecting passerby granted
okay acid
okay all right
please look more like a pigsty than a
house a heavy stench of crude old milk
cheap alcohol and boiled cauliflower
filled the air Hey back then in Africa
and I saw people ready to take up arms
to stand against the yoke of English
imperialism in Montreal mail boxes were
blown up abductions were carried out and
violent manifestos were distributed to
media outlets to do his curse out loud
against a faraway evil and pray for the
revolution to arise that man by any
reckoning was from that very stock
you had to be out of your mind to cook
up white whiskey at home all surrounding
stench of alcohol alone okay gasps oh
man to death are all now knew how to
quench the drunkards thirst
Vasia blue seems like that pig had named
after all funny in him
how's that funny okay I guess that's it
I if I could shower
okay so that means I could get up go
back to the [ __ ] tent
it's a one-way so we have to make anyway
it's got last one
I was
second I'll [ __ ] up here stop that
beer I got me Jerry go Jerry Carl felt
that it was mission accomplished with
the wicked nectar in his hands
I'm a baby but we got one my ass they
got a [ __ ] [ __ ] let's check out the last
day just for completion is up just for
completion ISM
say yeah what's up here
a great place to look all we got here
[ __ ] a lot you know
get out
well what the [ __ ] is this place
now you sparkplug sometimes and
especially around here people are so
possessive with their land as a dog is
with hydrants
and asking me to get back to ya
yes okay can I get it oh yeah get me the
[ __ ] in here break in there
there we go
another worrisome victim of this ice
this one son doesn't [ __ ] around in
action
the poor man before being frozen solid
seem to have been defending the entrance
to his cabin but from what ii loves
aliens [ __ ] [ __ ] aliens
aliens alien thing something very
important must have been in there for
the man to take such time and effort to
hide it but Karl didn't know how to
reach it the week of October 5th I've
expecting the plug should have been here
by now
that one good enough for me Sasa
like a [ __ ] heater in here
be its
okay I got a jump off some [ __ ]
[Music]
hey job offers [ __ ] real quick
and I know they have flash that out here
or Aladdin blue posit something that
[ __ ] god I can ask him Doug who's
good finder reputation he still hadn't
found any of the wealth contained in the
mutts lands
I get all this stuff liars and I also
need to pick up this like screw thing
Carl had a hunch that there had got to
be a plan somewhere that could help them
put this thing back together
music Philip Gaskin
oh [ __ ] like anyways to play this game
funny huh
I know it's the [ __ ] cars out here
that's really all I know
I'll be a dog anymore
okay that's gay nice carry on they say
it's supposed to soothe the soul but
with this powerful Gale that seemingly
never sleeps
it was far more likely to get on
anyone's nerves perhaps someone was
expecting an important call yeah in any
case that person is in for a long wait
Carl yes the telephone services weren't
provided in this area blankets well that
means that same story large deserts
conducive to extravagant follies you
could say that again sister price
the man has a passion for intergalactic
things back then people were obviously
scared of the Russian atomic bomb but an
invasive extraterrestrials was a legit
weird stuff kind of a crossing between a
colander and a hairdryer what was it for
to play telepath to protect against
nuclear waves
[Music]
[Music]
space cascara these scribblings were
undoubtedly the mark of a tormented mind
something wasn't right in the poor
mechanics hand
and see what I can do to repair this
thing by following the plan Carl was led
to believe that the snowmobiles parts
had to be scattered about in the
vicinity where
this is the track fact lights handlebars
and bench there any other skis head up
with the skis down [ __ ] second ski
yeah
we're gonna second pair of skis anything
down there hey
okay scarce kiss
I'll call that here's all I gotta say
what good was a motor less car the
mechanic sure had an odd way to go about
repairing things
anything in here check this one out
let's say nothing nothing okay really
good actually
one more ski okay
just checking here one my time shows it
here the bear spaceship
second night at 10:00 it was an
indisputable fact that machines like
this until the level of intellectual
finesse that Cara was lacking say one
pair of skis
we're gonna get some [ __ ] skis the
very first steps of man on the moon were
made more than a year ago the event had
surely captivated the mechanics mind for
him to still keep this around scary
scary
yes yes [ __ ] when she was together thing
up there
I guess nobody back
I'll be back
there's nothing up there
he's gotta be in this building
okay almost that just night one perished
his left and then my flutter
like a scary nice I guess
Karl deducted this was a map of the area
with those pins pointing to places of
interest yes where do you keep your
skills yes
hey [ __ ] it's get around here excuse me
escape food excuse me I'd like the main
entrance they crashed her here
skills
were you scared
yeah
what is that
alright look at the center here
[ __ ] the skeezer
yeah
all the [ __ ] over for this case and
you know what I don't say [ __ ]
one more pair of skis
[Music]
yes worse if you guys are watching has
anything like I'm sorry
yes sometimes our great say gays down
here
anyone got skiing at me
I really
[Music]
belike or something they have to be one
of the two buildings I can't be your
[ __ ] house are these boxes
no sign of skates
they're the style should have skis in
that area weird stuff
kind of a crossing because I lender and
a hairdryer what was it for to play
telepath to protect against nuclear
waves yeah
the sooner you find this case the sooner
we can I do
all right last ditch effort that he ever
get the [ __ ] out of here
Oh too much did away he really dead I
read this point
excuse me the walls hanging up now up
there Mike
okay well have you flitted they're in a
[ __ ] cave don't [ __ ] place alright
let's get the [ __ ] out of here [ __ ] here
well this trucks not going anywhere
yeah we got Anakin Stein desk are lying
around somewhere made of parts from a
dozen different vehicles every gallon
like this case worth a bit of gas that
new spark plug had the key and this
thing would run perfectly all he needed
to do now was to find all that
it's wrong what's in there
Wow what the [ __ ] is just another faster
way of doing this
have a gas can ethanol keys [ __ ] get the
[ __ ] out of here
[Music]
that's a gigantic wasted
Hey Hey
right now let's share this they can
actually go fly in the snow this cannot
be safe that
my big right that's for sure
how's that
I never went to like whatever the [ __ ]
is down there
this can't be good
[ __ ] cave
[Music]
I guess in here holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] up
holy [ __ ]
but hold seem to be more brutal here
than anywhere else
Oh deep tinta bones and into every
breath to get to the heart until it
stopped
I needed to be dressed in warm clothes
to survive okay
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] Brittles [ __ ] die
tonight oh my god
Carl wondered how long he would have to
enjoy this skin stinging cold and my son
got brown
because I'm getting the [ __ ] out here
I'm in I got [ __ ] up in there
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] blurry
[ __ ]
let me get back this [ __ ] Patriots
house dude take the only guy there
my god
oh my god okay see what I got it I got
the camera compare is it right Harry
you carry boo
Oh
[Music]
maybe I can
yeah
sorry okay
I guess win this one right here but it's
been very generous I couldn't devise
all right I guess I'll see you on the
next one day I say cavern right now but
right here all right take it easy on
thank ya